not rocket science you just have to do
the experiment and that's all there is
to it but actually doing it is
unbelievably hard work miserably
depressing most of the time and very
very hard
well I've been for a long long time
fascinated by how you control entry into
mitosis I mean you know what makes a
cell divided and why does it divide now
and not five minutes later or half an
hour earlier I would like to talk to Tim
hand because one of my projects was very
similar to what he is doing but I am
using a completely different approach
than he does I'm very excited to meet
professor Tim hunt because he's the
first person who discovers cycling
cycling is a very important molecule in
cell cycle cells grow and divide and
cycling it's a molecule that governs the
process not only dividing frog cells but
initially dividing starfish cells
finally dividing human cells this stuff
you could even be found in yeast it was
totally a universal substance that makes
cells and m-phase I'm doing cancer
biology now and we know that cancer
cells goes through a very fat cell cycle
or we can say their cell cycle
regulation is defected so I really want
to ask him how by understanding you know
how cell cycle is regulated we can find
out some way to cure cancer
but I heard you are working at Cancer
Research Institute this is true
I've only once seen a tumor actually we
were working we were collaborating with
some dentists and somebody brought up
this disgusting tray with a bit of
tongue that somebody had just cut out of
an 80 something-year-old
mani one felt very sorry for the guy you
know he just his tongue cut out
basically cuddley ugly tumor on the back
of it so you don't see any potential of
the like a cycling antibody in combating
cancer no no no I don't think so because
um you know early on everyone said oh
gosh you know you guys have done such a
great job defining the control of the
cell cycle now you can cure cancer but
it's nonsense if you think about it
because yes you understand a lot more
about how cell division is controlled
but you know what happens if you block
cell division you die in about a week
right the one thing that cancer cells do
rather well is divide everybody knows
that so they there's there's nothing
really wrong with with with the cell
cycle machinery unfortunately what is
wrong is that they grow when normal
cells wouldn't grow
I've heard that Tim hand is not really a
supporter of of systems biology but more
a skeptic he's saying that since biology
has promised a lot but not delivered as
much as it has promised
he's about chemists so he focused on
only one protein or two proteins only
but in systems biology we look at the
whole picture you know
a network and it's a very complex system
I'm using a completely different
approach than he does he's looking at
individual proteins in a more
traditional reductionistic point of view
while I'm more in a holistic point of
view trying to look at how does this
protein interact with all the other
proteins in the cell I'm going to try to
convince him that systems biology is
important stage and I'm now in the last
year of my PhD uh-huh and what are you
working on I'm working on systems
biology Network biology I think it's
kind of a nice complementary approach to
the traditional reductionistic way of
approaching biological problems I think
I think both sides spend more time
talking to it yeah yeah what do you
think about like this biology approach
you you are like studying from like a
single molecule and - well I would say I
was the systems biology station mitosis
is a as a start and the finish yeah yeah
stuff happens I consider that what I do
to be real systems biology and most and
what systems biologists say they're
doing there's not to be very useful in
explaining the kind of questions I want
to have answered in in biology and they
tend to get very up very hung up on
noise and things like that and I know
it's interesting I mean you know
sometimes they do very very ingenious
experiments I mean they you know they
hook up the beta-galactosidase gene to a
fluorescent reporter but actually you
know they tend to just show that Jacob
and Mono got it right in 1961 when we
performed the
a substrate prediction experiment the
biologists were very happy that we could
supply them with aliens to go and look
at exactly it has something like 50,000
human proteins you don't want to have to
look at every single one or test every
single one of them whether they might be
a substrate or not right and so that we
could kind of narrow them down a little
bit dubious about systems biology these
sort of static pictures of what
interacts with what I don't find very
illuminating you can't even tell whether
they're true or not actually it's one of
the serious serious issues and you know
you make these lists of things and it's
just and which are painfully acquired
over over time and it's very hard to
make sense of what it all what it all
means I must say yeah you know you're
just getting comprehensive which sydney
brenner is very scathing you know low
input high throughput know what's what's
his main skepticism loss was that he was
saying okay you have all this data but
you don't know what is what are the
functional consequences of what you see
and I think that's that's the the great
thing about combining the rejectionists
with a systems biology approach so that
you can first you offer some some lists
of genes of protein interactions to test
and then the other people can go into
the lab and test them individually
and try to find out what are their
functional consequences for the cell and
it's kind of important to combine those
two world when you know more about the
basics of the system so you know not
only all the components but also how
they interact with each other and then
you can try to build some more how do
you absolutely plain the salient details
yeah that's where I think that that you
have to to try to look for emergent
properties in there exactly okay when
when we take even if we have to take
some simplifying assumptions in order
that we can build up a model to describe
the system how it works so it is a
formatively complicated problem and I
think actually maybe a lot of people are
pretty naive about it the almond I think
that in order to understand those
complex systems we really have to go
into the dynamics do you want to watch
things happening over time I mean I
think that's that's what I learned very
early on you know everything we measured
was always had the time was always a
dimension in the thing and and the
trouble with a lot of what is call
systems biology is a very static people
are doing like dynamics like studies
analysis - yeah but not much of this
sort of physiological flux analysis I
mean things really changing over time or
the rates of change they tend to look
more specifically yeah I mean there
there's some flux based analysis and
metabolic systems but there there are
some in some form they are their father
than in the field of protein
interactions where I think that this is
biology is only at the beginning as far
as I'm concerned everything comes from
an observation yeah yeah in the first
place a reproducible observation and
then you just sort of follow it wherever
it goes and you ask questions about it
that's just the kind of scientist they
have whether that's good or bad
I think my advice to a sort of you know
practicing systems biologist is is to
spend plenty of time talking to real
biologists how can you sort of draw it
out on a system or sort of a logical
diagram even when you don't even know
what the players are in the process I
mean it just seems premature to me so
you've got a sort of new truffle around
and turnover stones and sort of notice
that things don't quite make sense and
sometimes that's more of a gut reaction
than a than something you know and I've
always had this sort of feeling of this
there are some very old observations
whose explanation we don't understand
you could not explain in rational terms
I think myself as a biologist now a
biologist who try to combine engineering
and math and physics I see there's a big
gap between biological science and
physical science and I really want to
bridge the gap between the two in the
future in my future career
so I mean like you think like people
from physics background or engineering I
think they should be able I mean I'd be
interested to talk to an engineer who
knew about plant design you know how why
does a particular pipe have to be -
given that it's got to conduct so much
engineering problem and those are the
people actually funnily enough who don't
we don't seem to talk to and I think
those guys know what they're doing very
very well indeed it's a question of
though how you apply those principles to
things that are much much harder to
measure in in living cells so what about
people from like multiple fields like
I'm double majoring in biology and
Chemical Engineering well that's great
Sophia turns out is doing a double major
in biology and Chemical Engineering and
I kind of feel that chemical engineering
is very much like the cell so she should
you know if he can sort of make those
connections I think that could be a very
powerful combination actually should
stand there in good stead if you can you
know be as quantitative so you have to
be for an engineer a chemical engineer
and apply that to the biological
situation that will be great really
great when I start out my PhD I had no
idea what to do absolutely none and
fortunately my first project didn't work
which is jolly lucky cuz I think I
wouldn't be sitting here now if it had
and then I had another one that didn't
get very far and it wasn't and you know
it took me about three attempts to find
something that really was actually an
important question was nobody else was
so and then it sort of seemed so obvious
that I got terribly worried that surely
there must be somebody else in the world
who was doing this and we were about to
be scooped you know you have to focus
but you also have to be distractible I
mean if something if something
interesting sort of crawls across your
path it's perfectly okay to
to go after it I always tell people you
know you need to keep your feet on the
ground and your eyes on the horizon and
your nose to the grindstone course you
know Oliver Smithies when always
Saturday morning experiments I'm a great
believer incidentally in Saturday
morning experiments as the sort of
simple ones where you just try stuff out
you